I think it's hard uh to separate
My Hope from my objective
intuition about
what super intelligence systems look
like
if one studies
evolutionary biology with a bit of math
and in particular like books from when
the field was just sort of like properly
coalescing and knowing itself like not
the modern textbooks which are just like
memorized this legible masks you can do
well on these tests but like what people
were writing as the basic paradigms of
the field were being fought out yeah in
particular like a a nice book if you've
got the time to read it is
adaptation and natural selection which
is one of the founding books
you can find people being optimistic
about what the utterly alien
optimization process of natural
selection will produce in the way of how
it optimizes its objectives you a lot of
people arguing that like in the early
days biologists said well like organisms
will restrain their own reproduction
when resources are scarce so as not to
overfeed the system
and
this is not how natural selection works
it's about whose genes are relatively
more prevalent to the Next Generation
and
if you if like you restrain reproduction
those genes get less frequent in the
Next Generation compared to your con
specifics
and
natural selection doesn't do that in
fact Predators over run prey populations
all the time and have crashes that's
just like a thing that happens
and many years later
uh well the people said like well but
group selection right what about groups
of organisms
and
basically the math of group selection
almost never works out in practice is
the answer there
but also years later somebody actually
ran the experiment where they took
populations of insects
and selected the whole populations to
have lower sizes you just take pop one
pop two pop three pop four look at which
has the lowest total number of them in
the Next Generation and select that one
what do you suppose happens when you
select populations of insects like that
well what happens is not that the
individuals in the population evolve to
restrain their reading but that they
evolve to Kill The Offspring of other
organisms especially the girls
so people imagined this lovely beautiful
harmonious output of natural selection
which is these these populations
restraining their own breeding so that
groups of them would stay in harmony
with the resources available and mostly
the math never works out for that but if
you actually apply the weird strange
conditions to get group selection that
beats individual selection what you get
is female and infanticide
like if you're like reading on
restrained populations and
so that's like the sort of so this is
not a smart optimization process natural
selection is like so incredibly stupid
and simple that we can actually quantify
how stupid it is if you like read the
textbooks with the math
nonetheless this is the sort of basic
thing of you look at this alien
optimization process and there's the
thing that you
hope it will produce and you have to
learn to clear that out of your mind and
just think about the underlying Dynamics
and where it finds the maximum from its
standpoint that it's looking for rather
than how it finds that thing that left
into your mind as the beautiful
aesthetic solution that you hope it
finds and this is something that was has
been fought out historically as the
field of Pop of biology was coming to
terms with evolutionary biology
and uh and you can like look at them
fighting it out as they get to terms
with this very alien inhuman pot
in human optimization process and indeed
something smarter than us would be also
be much like smarter than natural
selection so it doesn't just like
automatically carry over
but there's a there's a lesson there
there's a warning
the D natural selection
is uh is a deeply sub-optimal process
that could be significantly improved on
it would be by an AGI system well it's
kind of stupid it like has to like run
hundreds of generations to notice that
something is working it doesn't be like
oh well I tried this in like one
organism I saw it worked now I'm going
to like duplicate that feature onto
everything immediately
that's like run for hundreds of
generations for a new mutation tries to
fixation I wonder if there's a case to
be made in natural selection
as inefficient as it looks is actually
uh
is actually quite powerful that that
this is extremely robust it runs for a
long time and eventually manages to
optimize things
it's weaker than gradient descent
because gradient descent also uses
information about the derivative
yeah Evolution seems to be there's not
really an objective function there's a
there's inclusive genic Fitness
is the implicit loss function of
evolution just cannot change the loss
function doesn't change the environment
changes and therefore like what gets
optimized for in the organism changes
it's like take like gpt3 there's like
imagine like different versions of gpt3
where they're all trying to predict the
next word but they're being run on
different data sets of text
and that's like natural selection
always inclusive genetic fitness but
like different environmental problems
so it's it's uh it's difficult to think
about so if we're saying that natural
selection is stupid if we're saying that
humans are stupid
it's smarter than natural selection
smarter stupider than the upper bound
do you think there's an upper Bomb by
the way that's another painful place I
mean if you you put enough matter energy
compute into one place it will collapse
into a black hole and there's only so
much computation can do before you run
out of nagentropy in the universe dies
um so there's an upper bound but it's
very very very far up above here like a
supernova is only finitely hot it's not
infinitely hot but it's really really
really really hot